My name is Supa Mandiwanzira. I'm the chief
executive of Mighty Movies TV Production Company
in Zimbabwe. I think that the 2010 World Cup
will not only benefit South Africa, I think
it will benefit the region. But much of the
economic benefits will be found in South Africa
certainly because most of the people who will
be coming for the World Cup will becoming
to visit South Africa. Some may visit some
original countries, Zimbabwe, Zambia, Mallow,
and other countries that have fantastic tourist
attractions in the region. But what is important
also is that the focus on Africa will help
change the image of Africa across the world,
because there's a negative image about Africa.
Much of it is perception. It's actually not
a reality. But having the word media which
is coming to cover the football, and a whole
lot of people from outside the African continent,
will see for themselves that Africa is not
what it perceived out there. That Africa is
far much ahead then what they actually think
it is in terms of development, in terms of
opportunity, in terms of going forward. Thank
you.